great we got one more submission for
this past month and then next week I'll
let you know who won for this month now
for our best worst weekend here we go
hey Theo Colin for the best worst
weekend the boy Devin being gunned down
oh shut it my boy Devin be out in
Young's TZ boy Youngstown Ohio and
that's a great place to get a you know
you get a get some cornbread and get
[ __ ] up as well and get mugged maybe
even or even you know you know we're
also get into military homeward ah I
don't really know if I want to say some
that are bad weekend per se but this
weekend I just hung out with my dog and
volley man hung out with your dog and a
little did a little bit of ecstasy huh
hmm that sound like some David in the
nomes type of [ __ ] remember that cartoon
David in the nose and they had like
little gnomes and suddenly they had a
wolf or like a doll like a sled dog
hanging out with him and you're like
damn they got this big white dog hanging
out with this little you know frisky
little little person this [ __ ]
somebody's on ecstasy Oh word [ __ ] I
know that sounds weird but pretty sure
we connected I've got a different level
oh I bet you did do I mean I hope it was
all kind of stuff you could talk about
at the church you know long word [ __ ]
man ah okay and there you go man I don't
know is that bestiality or is that just
friendship what is it what did we just
hear guys what did we honestly just hear
I I do not know thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip and you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this because this is
alarming